hey guys I just got back from vacation
and contrary to popular belief I'm
actually not dead I just decided to take
a little bit of break after all my
friends came into town and we were
working like 18-hour days for seven days
straight I needed to just clear my head
a little bit but while I was away I
found that I really wanted to be back in
making videos again and I'm sorry for
the lack of videos I actually didn't
have time to prepare as much as I would
have liked because this vacation was
playing - while ahead and blah blah blah
I didn't tell you guys I said on
Facebook and Twitter I'm sorry for the
lack of videos over the past five days
but now I'm more ready than ever and
I've got so many things that I need to
tell you about first off Bob started his
own YouTube channel he finally did it
we've been telling him to do it for
years now and he finally is going to be
making gameplay content and other
amazing stuff for you guys as of right
now I think he has a vlog up announcing
what's going to be on the channel and
his first gameplay video so check him
out in the link in the description below
and one of the really cool things that
he talks about in his vlog is that he
only really wants to make a channel to
build up a community with which he can
point in the right direction and get to
do get them to do great things
which is all I've ever wanted about our
community and the great thing is that
the bigger their community gets the more
good we can do obviously that's you know
not really in question but the problem
is that there are so many people it's
hard to point you guys in the right
direction and I kind of let that slip
through the cracks because I've had
plans to make this happen for a while I
just haven't done anything about it but
now that I'm back and now that I know
that this is all happening now I want to
dedicate myself more to making sure that
you guys have a method by which to
interact with one another and organize
for these bigger events so I'm going to
be making a website one with a simple
forum system polling and blogging and
other features that you guys can suggest
in the comments below I want you guys to
tell me what you want the website but
I've had markiplier calm reserved for a
long time now I just didn't know what to
do with it and there were other things
that were planning for it and I've just
decided to forget all of that and just
get this place Marga Meier calm as a
for you guys all to rally the community
together and I want you guys to have a
place where we can all share our ideas
you know we can all promote each other's
you know big events that we want to do
we can organize charity things we can
organize different fun times playing
games with me playing games with each
other you know making things bigger and
better for our community as a whole
which is just one of the best
communities on YouTube by far and I'm
not even saying that just to stroke your
egos like you asked around and like just
check in the comments and some people's
YouTube channels and it's just it's
animalistic it's brutal not all but I
mean some of them are just like they're
constantly fighting and they're
constantly bickering with one another
and I've never seen that with ours and I
read a lot of the comments that you post
on videos and so I know what you guys
are saying and it really does more my
heart that you guys have been non-stop
supportive so I want to make a place
where we can all channel that effort so
thank you guys and that'll be up very
soon the other thing that I let fall
through the cracks valves on vacation
was that I was part of another guns of
Icarus tournament I know you guys love
the last ones because it was me Jesse
Cox cryotic and Dodger all together on a
ship against TB and his gnarly crew
pirates while we're pirates too but
they're also they're bad pirates we're
good we're not good pirates but we're
Pirates nonetheless stop that
either way there was supposed to be
videos on my channel announcing it but I
uploaded it before right before I went
to vacation and they didn't upload so
either way here is some of them good I
don't get it either I'm using glass mark
did he apply
oh that was a clever clever thing I did
oh oh yes horribly funny
taro that was great brother hear us
customising yes you get all excited yeah
we can you welcome back all the colors
of the winds online it's a rematch
against totalbiscuit and we're gonna
battle them again but first we're gonna
do some customization of our characters
and ship to make it the way you want so
this time we win something like that
that's good we'll go with that one you
know just use that yeah yeah that's
great I like the whole questioning tone
throughout the entire so yeah but I'm
not quite convinced of this myself but
we're gonna say later you should sound
convinced and be tomorrow
a world where four people get on this
steel butterfly they must first figure
out what colors they want for their
cooter that good yeah that's great but
we're gonna do the ship cuz our
characters already done but good god
damn you're still on the character bit
good job that's it we're done we did it
yay okay now well so anyway that's all
cool stuff that's coming in the future
I'm sorry for dropping the ball on the
number of videos over the past week but
I promise that I will get more engaged
in it in the future because I am more
dedicated than ever whatever I take a
break or vacation I'm always sitting
where I'm supposed to be having fun
going well this is kind of fun but I
could be home making videos right now
for my fans but then I decide that I'll
go ride a roller coaster or something
and it'll be more fun so either way
thank you guys so much I will hopefully
get the website up in about 2 or 3 weeks
here I'm gonna really really plow at it
and get it all out of the way and done
and rate for you guys to use as soon as
possible thank you guys so much for
believing in me and helping me with what
I do so sincerely thank you all so much
for watching and as always I will se you
in the next video
bye-bye